Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my New Avengers Marvel
Disney Plus video there are a bunch of
really cool announcements in the past
week a bunch of good news so we'll break
it all down if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos will do a new Amazon giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know which other
new Marvel Disney Plus series you want
them to do in the next couple of years
whatever it takes whatever it takes no
fears no regrets part of the journey is
the end I will be doing videos for all
the marble of Disney plus episodes when
each of the new series releases we
learned a little bit more about the
release dates for everything too that I
included in this video but starting with
number 5 the first really awesome thing
that happened this past week you may
have missed is we found that Marvel is
actually releasing way more content on
Disney Plus for each of the new series
than they originally told us mostly in
the form of extra episodes it started
with the Avengers Wandavision spin-off
series there's a ton of recent stuff
happening with that just because of how
big it is there's a lot of stuff
happening with all the different series
but if you've been really bummed out
with the movie delays Marvel revealed
unintentionally that they're doing 9
episodes of Wandavision instead of the
6 that they originally said that they
would this is a huge deal because
originally at the Marvel phase 4 Comic
Con panel and then the Marvel d23 panel
last year Kevin Feige talked about each
of their Disney Plus Avengers spin-offs
being like they were movies that
wouldn't get theatrical releases and
they'd just break them up into six
different parts HBO's kind of doing the
same thing with the Justice League
Snyder cut so Marvel is just making
super-sized movies that are six to eight
hours long and breaking them up into
different episodes the funny thing about
the Wandavision news is it actually
came indirectly because of some stunt
people in news leaking out so press F in
the chat for those people because they
probably just lost their jobs but
Anthony Mackie was also talking about
this recently this whole idea of 6 to 8
hour long movies so I'll explain that
when I get to the Falcon and Winter
Soldier stuff in a second but number
four right now Marvel has still said
Wandavision will start releasing episodes
in December they didn't list a specific
date but even if they double up on
episodes once or twice during the season
like they did during the mandalorian
season one Wandavision will still spill
into January so if you've always felt
like January
kind of a dead zone in terms of big
content from movies and TV it sounds
like Marvel is planning on changing that
going forward which i think is good news
for everybody if you understand Disney's
larger strategy to get people to
subscribe to Disney Plus it makes sense
they do this in order to get people to
pay for subscriptions they have to
release new content
people usually quit paying for the
service after seasons are over like
after the mandalorian season one bunch
of people just took off not going to pay
for this anymore until season two rolls
around so the more new episodes that
they release for all the Avengers Marvel
series for the Disney stuff for the Star
Wars series the faster they can grow
their service the exact same thing
happened to HBO for the last seven or
eight years with Game of Thrones you see
this giant spike in subscriptions when
Game of Thrones episodes are on then
after the season is over everybody just
bails on it number three next big
Avengers Disney Plus series Anthony
Mackie did a big falcon and Winter
Soldier interview this past week talking
about what's going on with the episodes
he did say that they barely barely have
anything left to film for their final
episode but they'll finish that this
summer now that people are allowing
movies and TV shows to film again he
said it's like a six to eight hour movie
so given what they're doing with Wandavision in the nine episodes expansion
I don't know if the six to eight hour
movie also implies that there'll be more
than six episodes of Falcon and Winter
Soldier but I think that behind the
scenes Disney and Marvel are trying to
figure that out because they've been so
starved to release new content that
they're just trying to expand everything
that they have right now in the pipeline
but don't be surprised if when we get
falcon in Winter Soldier if they do have
more than six episodes originally that
was going to release at the end of August
but that was before all the virus delays
the latest thing that Marvel has said
about new episodes is that they'll come
this fall the fall season officially
begins in September so just assume
sometime during September they would
have to overlap with the mandalorian
season 2 episodes if they delay it any
more than that the mandalorian season 2
actually good news here is the only
thing that Disney and Star Wars people
have said will not be delayed at all
they were lucky enough to finish filming
with the actors before the virus said so
all the episodes for that will start in
October they didn't list a specific date
so just vaguely assumed sometime around
mid October we'll start getting trailers
for a lot of
stuff later this summer we'll get the
Falcon to Winter Soldier full trailer
then we'll get the mandalorian season to
full trailer we'll get a Wandavision
full trailer but if you're big fan of
Mandalorian there'll be eight episodes
for season two just like there were for
season one I've already done a bunch of
videos about that so we'll add some
links in the description the Star Wars
people are plotting their series out for
Disney plus a little bit different from
the Marvel people but it's not that
different
there's just fewer overall Star Wars
series in the pipeline than Marvel has
Marvel is actually going to be releasing
three new Disney Plus series every
single year minimum starting next year
remember the whole goal for Disney
Marvel Star Wars is to have as many new
episodes every single week as possible
or just to keep people paying for their
service so number two they will release
a new master schedule for everything and
all the programming later this year so
it'll make a little more sense there is
a big Comic Con event happening this
summer there's actually a couple
different ones DC is doing their own
virtual comic-con but because they had
to cancel the San Diego Comic Con event
they're doing a virtual version of that
with a lot of publishers going we don't
know is they're going to drop any trailers
there but Marvel will probably do the
same thing as DC and do their own
special event online where they just
drop a bunch of trailers and release
information about what's going on with
all the series and all the movies that
are coming up during Marvel phase for
all the big Avengers Disney Plus series
that are coming next year are Loki in
the spring Loki from Avengers endgame
the Hawkeye series which is still
getting made with Jeremy Renner that's
still a thing in the Marvel what-if
series which is Marvel Studios first
big-budget animated series in all the
MCU actors are coming back for their
episodes of that and there are actually
10 episodes of the what-if series per
season with one episode for each MCU
movie so obviously a lot of the MCU
movies from the Infinity Saga won't be
covered till season 2 some of the Marvel
Disney Plus series will get multiple
seasons but some of them will just be
one season
they haven't really specified which is
which so we'll just find out about that
when we get new episodes there been a
lot of rumors about the series they have
in development there are rumors about a
scrolls Secret Invasion series happening
before Avengers 5 an agents of sword
series to be sort of a sequel series to
agents of shield because they're in
their final season right now maybe set
around Nick Fury's new space station and
they're introducing the sword
organization on the Wandavision series
later this year there's
the thunderbolts disney plus rumors
because of what's going on with Falcon
and Winter Soldier in the Black Widow
movie with the MCU villains that are
still locked up in the raft right now
led by Thunderbolt Ross a the number one
WTF probably the biggest new
announcement in terms of big Avengers
Disney Plus series a little while ago
was Mark Ruffalo saying that he's
pitching Marvel an Incredible Hulk
Disney Plus series that would be similar
to the original Incredible Hulk series
set on earth with him on the run episode
2 episode I am legally required by talk
show rules to ask you if we will see the
Hulk again I do know that I did give
Kevin Feige the blockbuster award at the
Hollywood Film Awards the other day to a
smattering of applause and and he did
say hey do you think there's any more
story left here and I said I could
probably come up with a few story lines
and he said well maybe you should come
in and we'll have a talk marble still
has a problem with the distribution
rights for Hulk movies which is why they
can't do a Hulk solo movie otherwise
they would have probably announced the
Hulk solo movie for Marvel phase 4 but
they can do as many Hulk TV shows as
they want which is why they were doing
the she-hulk TV series but back when
Black Widow was still coming out in the
spring we got all those other trailers
seeing Thunderbolt Ross there was a lot
of hype for Red Hulk Thunderbolt Ross
there was even a red hulk deleted scene
from avengers endgame but it would have
been a very different version of Red
Hulk because they didn't wind up doing
that now they can do a more comic-book
accurate version of that character they
haven't really announced what they're
doing with other Hulk family characters
because a lot of people wondered if
they're going to introduce Amadeus Cho is a
younger version of The Hulk for now Mark
Ruffalo is said that he's staying on as
the main version of MCU Hulk Bruce
Banner going forward into Avengers 5 I'm
only expecting some Easter eggs for Red
Hulk during Falcon and Winter Soldier in
the Black Widow movie but if they have
any huge post-credit scenes or teasers
for Thunderbolts Red Hulk or any other
Hulk family members I'll be sure to
include them in my videos remember there
are a lot of Incredible Hulk villains
that are still locked up in the raft
like the abomination the leader
they were originally going to do a whole
trilogy of movies with Edward Norton's
Hulk they had plans for a whole bunch of
other Hulk comic book villains to be
introduced in my last big Wolverine
video I also talked about how Mark
Ruffalo wants to do a Hulk crossover
movie with a Wolverine character in the
MCU but because they have their schedule
through most of Marvel phase 5 if they
do wind up doing something like that
it's going to be a long time before we see
that movie but they've been sleeping on
the Hulk for a while now in the MCU just
because of the weird rights situation so
let me know in the comments if they do
wind up doing an Incredible Hulk Disney
Plus series outside of Thunderbolt Ross
in Red Hulk who would you want the Hulk
to fight during that congratulations say
in Andrews you're the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video please
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details
everyone click here to watch Hugh
Jackman break down the Wolverine Marvel
movies and click here for my new
Wandavision trailer video in x-men Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe I'll see you guys
tonight!